I am the greatest but but did you
incubate us you're out there like I'm
living the dream do you mean living a
dream not in the dream you living I
don't end up doing things that are
destructive when I'm busy doing things
that are constructive the truth is I was
never a drug addict I just had too much
free time the people that operate this
planet the handful the one-percenters
have different information that you have
need motivation watch the top ten would
believe nation
he's Grant Cardone and here's my take on
his top ten ruse a success vol 17 and
joy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one
push yourself Muhammad Ali said he was
the greatest he said that before he got
in the ring I know a lot of you out
there think you you're like I am the
greatest but but did you a the brightest
you're out there like I'm living the
dream
you ain't living the dream that ain't a
dream you live it so when you're hearing
this and you're like yeah I like what he
just said yeah because you agree with it
but you needed it
because if you agreed with it that
doesn't help you grow things that I
agree with do not get me my growth
growth is typically painful it hurts
doesn't feel good I have to push through
it right think about the tree roots
growing they're having to push through
cement probably doesn't feel good so are
you pushing through cement are you
getting that extra segment in are you
doing this every day you know are you
pushing for the sale if you can't push
yourself how you gonna ever push
somebody else in the completion of an
activity in the successful completion of
an activity is where ladies and
gentlemen you will find yourself rule
number two
get addicted to productivity I don't end
up doing things that are destructive
when I'm busy doing things that are
constructive the truth is I was never a
drug addict I just had too much free
time and made bad choices
this planet is filled with bad choices
pornography strip joints casinos if you
were filled up all day long with
activities if you were addicted to
productivity if you were junky out on
potential you wouldn't have time for all
the other core
I would I wouldn't be I wouldn't spend
money on stuff I don't need
when is that money spent when do we
waste most of our money on this planet
during the holidays when we have free
time when do you spend your money when
do you go in debt on the holidays free
time so if I can just stay busy if I can
use time and create time how do I create
time I have 24 hours and I'm like I'm a
jam as much in those 24 hours as I can
and then I'll let you worry about me
burning out because that's what I'll
hear next
what about burnout when you're going to
burn out
look I'm 60 years old the more I do the
more I can do and the younger I get the
more I do the younger I feel the more I
do the younger my body feels I'm not
gonna burn out I'm not a candle I'm not
wax rule there are three show up a lot
of people talking about showing up some
people denigrating denigrating on my
showing up rule it is ladies and
gentlemen not 80% of success regardless
what anyone tells you it is probably
more like 99.9% of success anybody that
says otherwise is just trying to get
some attention unnecessarily because our
you love all you guys check it out like
if you don't show up you have no chance
of anything happening and once you show
up physically show up then you got a
chance of the rest of you showing up and
you'd be in freakin unbelievable
superstore but if you don't show up for
the audition the sales call to speak
whatever it is yourself for work man
nothing if you don't show up and buy
that lottery ticket you can't win it
then you got to get a little lucky then
you got to persist then you got do all
the other things you gotta do but first
you gots the show bug rule number four
don't let others label you look man I've
been labeled OCD a CD compulsive
obsessive see OD bipolar you know they
wanted to put me on lithium Prozac all
this medication okay I mean real real
like serious drugs I'm not talking about
smoking weed on the weekends and that
was supposedly to handle my energy or my
creativity or the fact that I didn't
like sitting in a chair for 45 minutes
at a time in school listening to a
history class of something that happened
300 years ago that had nothing to do
with me when I'm sitting there saying
hey listen I just want to learn how to
make some money man so you know it's
finally when I quit letting everybody
all these average people label me and
said you know what I'm gonna take this
obsessive-compulsive this this whatever
this energy is that has been you know
made wrong by society I'm gonna take
this energy and I'm not gonna suppress
any more and I'm gonna use it so for all
the kids all the kids out there
teenagers that are being mislabeled
millenials millenials a label man
introvert is a label lazy is a label
that nobody's lazy nobody is born lazy
these labels are being given to people
incorrectly and the truth is nobody's
actually lazy okay you're not born lazy
you're made lazy you're allowed to be
lazy you're encouraged to be lazy you're
surrounded by a bunch of people that are
lazy and then you become lazy people
that are being labeled OCD ATD ADHD I
think they're geniuses it's waiting for
you there's this big gift sitting there
waiting to bubble up don't medicate it
and don't push it down give it a voice
let it be greatness and genius rather
than something bad also if you want to
learn to have more confidence check of
my 250 for confidence series it's free
the link to join is in the description
below you have to go build
self-confidence rule number five take
responsibility
president of Mexico was on the following
me today now
no I'll tell you what it was because
I've been making decisions to change my
network I'm tired I open oh I'm sick and
tired of the same group that maybe for
whatever reason they're just not happy
with something I did and he did that he
did this and he said that not even like
that dude I'm like okay I don't want to
play big game I need a new story right
so I made the decision I went on the
chalkboard and started saying new
friends new network don't complain about
them they are where they are it's not
anybody else's fault now whatever I'm
getting in - fine yeah that game yeah
what a different game yeah you game
because everybody else is hanging around
those people they're fine they're all
having a good time and I'm the one
disappointed so I'm the one that has to
go to the white the chalkboard and map
out oh I need a new network it's not his
fault it's not don't be disappointed
with me I needed to change nobody else
in the world needs to change and so ever
since I was 25 years old when I went to
a treatment center and and had to
confront my drug addiction the one thing
I learned that that was so valuable was
you hat you are responsible then they
confused me with you're responsible but
it's not really your fault because you
got a disease which one is responsible
or do I you know and I chose to say hey
it's not the deceased I am responsible
and I haven't used drugs for 35 36 years
so now I need to apply that same that
same calculation to oh I want to change
my network on the phone with the
President of Mexico rule number 6 master
sales you need to learn how to
communicate with people okay
the the site here says the PowerPoint
says learn to become a professional
salesperson when I know when I think of
the professional salesperson
I think about a professional
communicator someone knows who knows how
to make contact someone who knows how to
control a conversation I don't think
about a swindler I don't think about a
tricky dude I don't think about a
huckster I don't think about a scam
artist I think about dude this guy
showed me something I didn't know you
have any things that I almost bought
were the wrong thing but a professional
salesperson with a full pipeline said no
no no you don't want that when one of
the best salespeople I know okay guy
named Robert I'm not gonna give his last
name because I don't have permission I'm
sure he wouldn't mind 25 billion dollars
where the real estate hey Robert is this
a good deal you know but that's not the
one I would do I would I would buy this
one over here if I were you okay see see
he's a professional he's a communicator
he'll tell me when I'm doing wrong he'll
tell me when I'm right tell me when I'm
wrong he'll challenge me he's not
playing games trying to like match tones
I saw this video the other day matching
people something did you see it okay
right at the right moment at the right
moment lower your voice and I don't want
to do that I'm talking about a
professional salesperson doesn't have to
rely on tricks because their pipelines
so big there's seven billion people on
the planet that are qualified and
interested in buying your product you do
not need to trick people and that's what
so many people think commission I don't
want to be a salesperson equals I don't
wanna be a huckster well you don't have
to be if you're a professional rule
number seven be obsessed with success my
mother was there for me when I didn't
need her to be there for me okay okay
she didn't she never let me down but but
that doesn't mean she pushed me up you
understand the difference my mom was a
great mother she was always there for me
it didn't mean she pushed me up to the
next level though because every time I
went to my mom and said mom let me tell
you what I'm doing she would be like
that's awesome
but just son remember I love you just
the way your how many of you have a
character will tell you that just
remember I was 15 years old she would
still tell me that she's 70 she was 78
at the dam she's like just remember I
love you just threw a are you've done
enough wins enough enough man you're
doing fine
I love you just the way you love
yourself the way you are I'm like but I
don't I can't lie to myself I do not
love this no months I don't shut nose on
a dog milk Chuck ates itself Chuck knows
he can do more chime all right Chuck and
then he's trying to communicate that to
his wife for his wife to get it and his
wife is like Chuck what's wrong with you
you broken Chuck you need a therapist
okay and then he's gonna go see the
therapist like I did and the therapist
is gonna be like oh yeah you got a DD
you got you got the OCD you got the the
OPD you got the OCD AC DD DD
[Music]
you know I said no I got the the o SD
I'm obsessed with success disease
I'm obsessed and I want my damn $200
back don't tell me I'm a DDD I'm taking
offense to that okay I don't add I
multiply I'm sure and I'm trying to
figure out how to run 70 businesses and
have 70,000 employees I'm not worried
would we what you worried about you
worried about how many browsers I got
open in my mind
rule number eight study the 1% the
people that operate this planet the
handful the one percenters
have different information that you have
okay they're not talking about going to
college they're not talking about saving
money
you don't hear wealthy people talking
about I need to buy a house
[Music]
Warren Buffett you know Warren Buffett
Warren Buffett is not a I need to buy a
house I have to have a home to live in
Warren Buffett bought one house his
whole life he never talks about what's
he by he's buying businesses which he
invested his money in businesses right
he's not buying a house where money dies
rule number nine invest with Steve Jobs
died when Steve Jobs died where did his
money come from one place was Apple he
owned some Apple stock but that was not
the majority of his wealth majority of
Steve Jobs wealth when he died was from
no iTunes is Apple no it was an
investment look it up what's the name of
the company everybody's gonna know the
name of the company assume it Pixar
Pixar Pixar he owned he he was at he was
one of the fountain three founders of
Pixar that's where most of his wealth
was from investments so to get to the
top of the food chain you got a to get
to the legacy will to be able to leave
your family something which is really
what everybody wants to do know every
once you have the BMW's you have the
BMW's once you have the country-club you
have the country club once you have the
Gucci belt you have the goods you've got
once you go on a yacht trip you go on
the agent once you fly first class well
you've done it even when you go out and
buy your own plane you've done it at
some point you're gonna be like okay now
what now what when do I start giving
back you're not going to give back to
society until you create indestructible
wealth which is really what everybody
wants to do everybody wants to give more
and help out more and make a difference
and rule number ten the last one before
very special bonus clip is change how
many of you want to change
two things if you want to change number
one you got to change you want you want
to change a little bit change a little
bit you want to change a lot change a
lot to change you gotta change and
number two you have to learn how to talk
to people you got to learn how to
communicate you have to learn how to
stand on a stage and communicate maybe
it's not this stage maybe it's not
thirty five thousand people maybe it's
one person that's a stage your house is
the stage you're going to talk to your
spouse your business is a stage you're
going to be talking to the Treasury
Department selling them stop the madness
stop the madness we're not gonna save
money here we're gonna make money here
we're gonna go getting money here you're
gonna have a stage with your lawyer your
lawyers gonna say don't do it stop the
madness
your lawyer dude I'm running a business
tell me how we can do it
I don't ask for yours and accountants
for business advice record the data
you're an accountant do the job you're
the lawyer let me run the business into
the ground
the game we will run it into the ground
we're gonna do it France way
not the lawyers way and not the
accountants way
two things you got to do to change folks
you got to change and you need an
audience now I've got a special bonus
tip from Grant on how to 10x your life
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing question let's go
from just watching a video to taking
action here we go question number one
what's one big change that you need to
make number two where do you need to be
more productive and number three who are
three one-percenters that you want to
study their success what is 10x what is
it for you
10x is defined as a concept where you
would scale your business and/or your
ideas to which point you would create a
life not a business you would create a
life without limitations my business
gives me my life I didn't have that for
20 years for 20 years my business had me
say 10x if you could if you know what
I'm talking about your business owns you
worried about it scared about it
concerned about it won't spend money
over it worried about the next thing
worried about the lawsuit worried about
the threats worried about the
competition that's not freedom 10x how
big how big would my ideas how big would
my business need to get that I could be
protected
freedom how can I get some freedom in
America we live in a place where freedom
is pitched every day land of the land of
the brave is it land of the brave home
of the brave land of the free
if you want more grant cardone and check
out the top 50 rules video I made on him
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there if you're
not gonna work like a 10-hour day as a
short day for me I hear more people
promoting this for our idea okay